[Music]
for
oh
[Music]
o
[Applause]
[Music]
than
for
[Music]
a
the
[Music]
play
[Applause]
well hello
everyone it's my immense pleasure to
present uh to you all these two
wonderful musicians in and Friends uh
joio so my longtime teacher on seven
[Applause]
string and our feature for today Thiago
sza on
theion and I believe many of you speak
Portuguese
correct okay okay so you get to hear
directly
from
[Music]
for
for so the next tune well I guess for
those that don't speak Portuguese we
played kosi shandu by pish kind of the
guy of Brazilian music and then we
played sh GAF is more of a Samba and now
we're gonna play a tune called
AR which they don't like the way that I
do that with the rollar so I do it just
to mess with them um and then this is by
esales who's from s
Paulo
n
[Music]
I
the
[Music]
a
[Applause]
w fire all
[Music]
think
n
[Music]
[Applause]
must
okay okay so this is this tune is dango
and this is a tune that um I already
forgot how many of you speak Portuguese
here
so oh okay almost everybody so this is a
tune that was com by composed by Jonah
Silva which is a a man that lived in
basically the same building with hu so
it's kind of a guy from the family
[Laughter]
here I just I I don't think I need to
do
ah so we have a very um uh special guest
that we'd like to bring to the stage now
Savio L on
base Savio is uh I think we first met in
Brooklyn correct me if I'm wrong yeah
there there's a there used to be a very
nice H in in Brooklyn Jam a shter jam
session and we first met there but then
it turns out that uh Flavio had studied
seven string guitar this guitar that was
has in the past
in was very I don't know maybe it was
getting it was a crowded Market I'm not
sure what inspired the change
uh the the I started in the base so then
the the crowded Market took me to the
seven string
guitar but then I came back okay so you
went home
got but but everything I learned from
the seven string and from hu especially
I tried to bring it into the base cuz
they kind of perform similar roles in
the
[Music]
music
there
n
[Music]
yeah
that's
you
get
[Music]
yeah
n
C
oh
[Music]
w
[Applause]
foreign for speech
fore
speech that was that
[Music]
by
ah
[Music]
la
he
[Music]
VIs
oh
[Music]
wait
[Applause]
for
[Music]
El we'd like to invite another special
guest to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
Isabella
Saye
[Music]
fores J
me
[Music]
foree fores
me
[Music]
love
you
[Music]
fish B
pH
[Music]
oh
for they
they
face those love you
[Applause]
[Music]
for
pH pH b f
s
phes b
[Music]
pH thank
you
[Music]
fall
speee
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
foreign
she
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
the
h
[Music]
they
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Applause]
[Music]
for thank
you
[Music]
so we've been slowly wending our way
from kind of older music influen by uh
jazz in Brazil to more recent stuff I
mean roughly
right so we just played a tun DEA by bad
PA
guitarist um kind of divider of AAS and
know oh my gosh that came out in both my
is a mess from this week uh constantly
back and forth um okay so divider of
waters that's what I'm looking for um
and now we're going to move forward
TOA this is one of the standards by
Ja um who is kind of another divider of
a oh my God it's almost like I scripted
it
I'm um okay I'll stop
talking Portuguese
[Laughter]
he was trying to say
Waters that's what saying the basist
always has
jokes they
go
[Music]
that
n
[Music]
steady
wonderfully
[Music]
oh
y
[Music]
[Applause]
w
okay so we're reaching that
time and we'd like to thank some people
to thank David
[Music]
Jackson fortunately we didn't get the
chance
yeah um
and I'd like to thank all the the folks
kind of around David that have been
helping us kind of in the background
helping everybody make this whole thing
the the conference that you've been
having wonderful our experience
wonderful here so I'd like to thank them
too you Danielle
somewhere thank guy on the camera
there and uh I'd like to thank Asia I'm
not sure if I haven't seen oh you're
there
[Applause]
um and uh well I'd like to thank these
guys of course and Isa as well
[Applause]
so have you changed your last name I
don't even know this Isabella menes but
I doab for Artic okay so
Isabella
yeah and Flavia L on
base
speak I'll get so that we can build up
to a climax my name is Steven all
right and thenan seven string
guitar and our special feature here
tonight Chago
sza it's been a wonderful pleasure to
play for you all tonight it's kind of
not a very nice day outside is it um we
don't know we've been at the conference
oh okay good that's wonderful then so
we'll play one more tune this is
actually one that I composed and that
they liked down in Brazil when I was
recording the album uh so it's just kind
of caught on and I'm very happy about
that so this is
called if you're wondering what all love
that about it's not about drugs I assure
you um Chu is my friend in Buffalo
actually plays bluegrass
and in Buffalo you might imagine it's
hard to find Sho players so I've been
kind of chasing after him for a while
you know Bluegrass players it's very
similar instrument uh and so then one
day he said oh I don't have a problem
with offbeats because a lot of this
music is very syncopated right I don't
have a problem with Off beats I said
okay fine I'll write you a composition
with only Off beats and so
that's
couple of
months
spee
[Music]
right
n
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
n
let
[Music]
e
[Applause]
[Music]
n
[Applause]
d
spee
[Music]
Eng
spee
speech fore
speech
[Music]
la
f
[Music]
n
d
[Music]
yeah
got
[Music]
n
[Applause]
w
[Music]
good